the jurgen experience it's just
interesting that you were able to fight
and to train a full camp for a guy like
volkanowski especially a rematch
with no sparring with no partners with
no nothing
yeah we had a lot of we had a lot of
like uh mental stuff mental training you
know there's a lot of mental things and
uh like visualization yeah like i got to
visualize or even just think of
think of new new ways to move or i i got
to think of ways to set up stuff like i
just had more time to myself to think
about actual
actual fight and and whatever and then
even with the uh
with the sparring like the second fight
for the guitar we didn't spar but i
moved with my partners you know we
grappled or
we had stand up we had ideas of this how
he moves so i just got used to the
movement and
and we keep on on certain things and
that's it but was nothing ever like
cracking you you know like i would get i
mean you know how it is you see all
these guys they say like i got hurt
sparring i got respond that's all my
injuries came i got hurt from grappling
hard or sparring hard
so if you just take that out you know
like you get a 200 percent of yourself
but
it comes a point like everybody thinks
i'm i'm telling everybody to stop
sparring you know i'm telling the young
kid to stop smart i'm not telling the
young kid to stop sparing
when i was 16 i had to spar but it comes
a point where
you spar enough to the points where
everything happens or even fights like
i fought injured i sparred injured you
know i got i got
i got hurt i had to come to stuff like
you need these times
before the show because when it comes in
the show and you get hurt in a fight or
something you panic
you get buzzed in the fight you panic
but then if you do it in the sparring or
these amateur fights then
it's it's simple but when you get to
that yeah when you get to that certain
point
then you start sparring and you save
your brain because like right now
i would say at least 85 to 87
or even close to 91 of the ufc fighters
you don't have to you know if you didn't
come true to the
contender series i think you don't have
to really uh
spar anymore you know like yeah we're
all at a high level already of thinking
and doing this like
there's other ways that you could do to
figure stuff out you know and
that's just what i think you know i'm
not telling you so do you guys do a lot
of drills with pads
yeah pills with pads or even drills
drills on drills you know like you know
not like
not really dutch way but like more
uh towards a fighter yeah yeah
yeah and then we practice it yeah and
i'll practice it you know like we look
we look for um whenever i watch tape we
look for consistencies
guys that they do consistent movements
all the time and we work for those
movements
and then we go we apply we ask my
partner to go and now it's much
it's much more easier to ask someone to
uh
replicate this guy from me while we're
moving versus
to ask someone to replicate somebody
when we're sparring hard because i would
spar hard with them
freak this i give him a better look when
i'm
training uh when i'm doing myself so i'm
gonna go to that but that's not it
you know even if you give me a better
look as yourself i'm trying to
i'm trying to get ready for this guy you
know what i mean yeah and a lot of
people
that's when eagle and stuff come in and
and so on and so on so
i think uh i think so we figured out a
way where it worked for me and
and you guys got to see you know it's
like i just i felt so good my bot
everything was like everything was fun
if you don't understand how good calvin
kater is you don't understand how good
your performance is because yeah i i
talked to
you yeah i thought kevin k was a and it
takes two and i tell everybody with um
with this the numbers and stuff you know
like the reason why i didn't hit this
numbers
against uh against ortega is because we
went only four rounds you know what i
mean like
yeah just uh like i like our tech is a
different beast too you know i think so
the ref said what it said and that's
what happened in that fight but
like qatar had a like it was crazy
because one of the rounds i think so
like the third or fourth round i hit him
and uh he was just gone like i was like
he was gone attending it around i was
like oh this guy's not walking out for
the fifth round there's no way
am i [ __ ] jumping up and down yeah
like
like it was the first round i was like i
was like okay then
there's my answer uh if you would you
feel like getting punched some more my
friend we're gonna we're gonna do this
no he's tough as [ __ ] man because there
were a lot of moments in that fight
where he could have quit
wait wait he could have and it's crazy
because like you see it
you see him you see him get to that
moment like i feel it like it's right
there
and he just throw like a bomb and he he
lands it on me i'm like
i'm like what i like what i'm like come
on man and then like i hear everything i
can hear his corner yelling at him and
stuff and this and that i'm like
god damnit hater i was like you know i
was like i was like one time i was like
uh
um what was funny was at one time in a
fight like
he was just [ __ ] throwing and he
somehow landed a left hook or overhand
on me and he was on the fence
and i was like oh if i was about to get
finished like come on care just like
come on just do it but then you know
at the end of the day it's like it's not
my job you know i can't i can't focus on
what the ref going to do what is
what is uh if his team is going to throw
in a tie it's got focus on him you know
do you think they should have stopped
that fight at any point in time i mean
at the end of the day i'm in cater shoes
like me talking as a fighter
no way i was like give me a shot and
this guy's you know this
he's a puncher he's a puncher puncher
like this guy can like put someone down
you know but
you know it's funny because like teddy
alice said the same thing but teddy is
like telling me when i was on his show
he was like oh he was like
but max you never got dropped so i don't
know the odds of
the odds of him knocking you out because
he's a puncher puncher he's still not
there you know it stayed slim
but it is there but at the end of the
day i i can't speak on that you know
because as a fighter i'd be like frick
you know
leave me in there you know i want to
fight you know like even like
even my way with even like even
championship you know you want to find
the best guy right
and and the way i look at it is like if
it's the best it's not
a fight is a fight until
until it's over and then it's people's
pers uh
perceptions on the fight so after the
five rounds then it's a fight you know
like
but i thought this supposed to be the
two best guys in the world you know what
i mean like
my my take on it was like why why don't
we just have these fights yeah we have
the rounds
we're just going to someone wins the
fight right
instead we we keep this perception out
of it we just keep going around after
five rounds guess what we're going to
six guess what we're going to say we're
going to someone quit that's how you
find the best
fighter in the world at that weight jack
johnson style
why not you know that's the way i think
because it's just perception is this a
perception right because they'll never
do that in america but they might do it
in asia
yeah like maybe you could talk one fc
yeah one like i might be doing some wild
stuff like that
they see some wild stuff catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on
spotify including clips easily
seamlessly switch between video and
audio experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience